we begin this hour with breaking news
from there not so good where
team usa gymnast simone biles is out of
the team competition
the reason is not clear but she was
reportedly seen with a team doctor
she is not out of the individual
competition at least
not yet a statement said simone has
withdrawn from the team final
competition
due to a medical issue she will be
assessed daily
to determine medical clearance for
future competitions but obviously yeah
a heartbreaking for team usa and of
course for simone biles herself yeah
we're all worried about her and hope
that she can come back and continue with
the individual competition
whatever this is we're certainly pulling
for but it's been clear to us that she's
been feeling the pressure she said so
yesterday
that statement i feel the weight of the
world but you just which is
you've it's crushing to hear her say
that and not to have her parents in the
stands
yes that's for the first time so we are
pulling for you
team simone and team usa